[Música]
España irá a elecciones anticipadas el
próximo 23 de Julio tras El Triunfo de
la derecha y la extrema derecha en las
municipales y regionales del domingo el
presidente del gobierno español El
socialista Pedro Sánchez Busca dar un
golpe de efecto y movilizar a la
izquierda en las generales Tenemos
reporte desde Madrid y desde Barcelona
líderes internacionales reaccionan a la
victoria de receptaib erdogan en las
presidenciales de Turquía Suecia anunció
la reanudación de los diálogos sobre su
ingreso a la otan mientras el mandatario
Turco enfrenta un nuevo mandato marcado
por la crisis económica
empieza en París la Cumbre internacional
para limitar el uso y la producción de
plásticos un encuentro con divisiones
sobre el futuro inmediato de este
material presente en un gran abanico de
productos y fuente de contaminación de
nuestros ecosistemas
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
maceu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición informativa en
España porque este lunes el presidente
del gobierno el socialista Pedro Sánchez
convocó elecciones generales anticipadas
para el próximo 23 de Julio una reacción
que intenta movilizar de inmediato a la
izquierda para frenar el auge de la
derecha y la extrema derecha que
arrasaron en los comicios municipales y
regionales de ayer domingo y desde
Madrid nuestra corresponsal Marina
Colorado nos tiene todos los detalles
vuelco electoral hacia la derecha en
España en los comicios municipales y
regionales el domingo y vuelco a la
agenda política nacional de los próximos
meses tras el inesperado anuncio de
disolución de las Cortes y de
convocatoria de elecciones generales
anticipadas para el 23 de Julio en una
declaración institucional desde el
Palacio de la moncloa de menos de 3
minutos el presidente del gobierno de
España Pedro Sánchez ha asumido
personalmente la derrota del psoe y
considera que la respuesta a estos
resultados es someter su mandato
democrático a la voluntad popular
Alberto Núñez feijo líder de la
oposición y del partido popular asegura
que España está convocada a derogar el
sanchismo el 23 de julio y pidió una
mayoría Clara y contundente un resultado
que necesitaría el partido popular para
no tener que formar coalición con la
ultraderecha de vox como ha de hacer
ahora para gobernar en varias regiones y
ciudades españolas la maquinaria
electoral se pone en marcha y de
gobierno de Sánchez podemos muy mal
parados el domingo tienen unos 10 días
para anunciar si se presentan a las
elecciones generales en coalición con el
proyecto sumar de la vicepresidenta y
ministra de trabajo Yolanda Díaz que es
la política mejor valorada del país en
estos momentos para que así la
ciudadanía progresista tenga nuevas
opciones en las urnas la campaña
electoral en España empezaría el 7 de
julio una semana después del inicio de
la presidencia española de la Unión
Europea un mes en el que además se
celebran la Cumbre de la otan y El
encuentro entre la Unión Europea y la
celac y tras estos comicios Barcelona
sería la única gran ciudad del estado
español que no estaría gobernada por la
derecha del partido popular que sin
embargo arrasó en Madrid Valencia o
Sevilla y precisamente desde la capital
catalana nuestra corresponsal el is
gasengel nos amplía
en Barcelona los resultados de los
comicios de anoche también fueron muy
decepcionantes para la izquierda Xavier
Díaz el candidato nacionalista Catalán
de centro de gecha ganó estas
municipales con un 22% de los votos 11
concejales pero podría no ser alcalde
finalmente si las izquierdas se unen y
esto al menos es el deseo de adakola
alcaldesa actual candidata de la
izquierda alternativa Quién hizo un
llamamiento anoche a la unión de las
fuerzas progresistas con los socialistas
que sacaban 10 concejales segunda fuerza
ella y su partido 9 concejales y la
izquierda independentista que sacó cinco
Barcelona es la única gran ciudad del
estado que podría gobernar la izquierda
eso fue un aviso del portavoz de colau
que hizo esta misma mañana en los tres
partidos hasta el 17 de junio para
pactar pero esta Alianza sega muy
complicada y las figuras políticas de
los tres partidos a nivel nacional
tengan un peso muy importante en estas
negociaciones unas negociaciones que
padecerán un ensayo en general antes de
los comicios de estas elecciones
legislativas adelantadas para el 23 de
Julio cambiamos de información y es que
en Turquía tras revalidar mandato
receptor enfrenta grandes retos
económicos con una inflación que supera
el 40% y con una constante devaluación
de la moneda de hecho tras conocerse los
resultados de las elecciones de ayer la
lira turca cayó a un mínimo histórico
frente al Dólar Juan Armando rojas tiene
los detalles
un mismo presidente para un mismo
flagelo una tasa de inflación anual
cercana al 45% que se ubica entre las
más altas del mundo tras la reelección
de relejectaipe erdoan lo que más
preocupa a los turcos son las medidas
que se tomarán para frenar el alto costo
de vida analistas creen que llegó la
hora de dar un viraje a la política
económica pues consideran que la actual
estrategia de bajar las tasas de interés
ha provocado mayor carestía
el enfoque poco ortodoxo del Banco
Central con respecto a la política
monetaria ha visto aumentar la inflación
ha cobrado un alto precio en la lira y
ha creado una gran brecha de
financiamiento externo esto ha
contribuido a un gran Éxodo de
inversores Internacionales del país
ahora esto contrasta con el tamaño de la
economía Así que pensamos que un regreso
a políticas más ortodoxas Un regreso a
la normalidad en el marco de políticas
en realidad podría revertir esta salida
en el futuro
el presidente reelecto para un periodo
de 5 años defiende su modelo de bajas Y
promete resultados
si alguien puede hacerlo lo haremos
nosotros la tasa de interés se ha
reducido al 8.5% en este momento verán
que la inflación también bajará además
de la inflación los turcos padecen la
pérdida de poder adquisitivo por cuenta
de la depreciación de la lira que ha
caído un 7% frente al Dólar este año y
más de un 90% en la última década
vamos ahora con noticias de la guerra en
Ucrania porque este lunes después de
lanzar una contraofensiva en la
madrugada el ejército ruso volvió a
atacar con drones la capital ucraniana
un ataque que las fuerzas de kiev
aseguran haber interceptado y por otro
lado desde la línea de frente de
saporilla en el sur del país nuestra
enviada especial Catalina Gómez Ángel
nos indica que el ejército ucraniano
alista ya la esperada contraofensiva
la llegada del buen tiempo hace que
transitar por las vías que conducen a
las áreas del frente de la provincia de
saporilla sea más fácil y rápido
tal como lo necesita la unidad de drones
que cumple una tarea establecida por su
comando
en un bosque cercano han localizado una
posición enemiga
estamos preparando para despegar el dron
Estamos buscando hombres que estén allí
y sus equipos la misión requiere que el
dron vaya cargado con una granada que
deben lanzar a una trinchera para eso
deben trabajar rápido y en coordinación
algo que estos tres amigos de infancia
convertidos en militares a causa de la
guerra han aprendido después de más de
un año de vivir en el frente
en nuestra dirección la Infantería del
enemigo se ha incrementado al igual que
su armamento esta región de saporilla
está llamada a ser uno de los puntos
estratégicos de la contraofensiva que
planea Ucrania buscarían avanzar hasta
el mar de asop y cortar el acceso ruso a
la Península de crimea desde la región
ocupada del Don Baz
estos drones ayudan a minar la moral y
tienen consecuencias psicológicas en el
enemigo Cuando llegamos a este lugar se
sentían muy seguros nos llevaban y
cascos ni chalecos pero gracias regalos
que les dejamos caer tienen pérdidas y
ahora se mueven rápidamente
estas misiones son cada vez más
frecuentes
en este otro video se ve como las
fuerzas rusas siguen cavando trincheras
al otro lado de la línea y cómo gracias
al trabajo de reconocimiento de estos
drones logran detectarlos y atacarlos
ellos no cambian de posiciones sus
mandos no los dejan siempre están
esperando no ellos no cambian de
posiciones sus mandos no los dejan
siempre están esperando es muy duro
desde el punto de vista psicológico
sentarse en las fronteras y estar bajo
nuestros ataques continuos
la contraofensiva será difícil y los
pondrán límite pero dicen que la están
esperando como un niño espera la Navidad
y ahora cambiamos de tema porque este
lunes el nuevo presidente de Nigeria ha
Jurado su cargo el exgobernador de lagos
bola tinuvo ASUME así el reto de dirigir
el país más poblado de África y con la
mayor Economía del continente veamos
ASUME la presidencia de la nación más
poblada de África y la mayor Economía
del continente
volatinubu de 71 años promete continuar
el legado de su predecesor mujamado
pujary
preservaré protegeré y defenderé de la
Constitución de la República Federal de
Nigeria que Dios me ayude
[Música]
bolatino búho ha prometido unir a todos
los nigerianos y ello a pesar de que su
elección ha sido impugnada ante los
tribunales por los partidos de la
oposición durante la campaña prometió
crear empleo e invertir en agricultura e
infraestructura públicas pero la mejora
de la seguridad sigue siendo una de sus
principales preocupaciones mientras el
presidente saliente luchaba contra los
militantes islamistas en el noreste de
Nigeria otros grupos han surgido en
otras partes del país
me siento realizado por haber iniciado
el renacimiento de Nigeria dando los
pasos críticos iniciales Y estoy
convencido de que la administración
entrante acelerará el ritmo de esta
labor
además de la seguridad uno de los
mayores retos del presidente tinubu será
arreglar el estado de la economía
nigeriana Nigeria se enfrenta a niveles
récord de deuda altas tasas de inflación
y una moneda débil y aunque el ex
gobernador de lagos ha prometido reunir
a las mejores manos para dirigir el país
los analistas se preocupan por el nivel
de responsabilidad que traerá su
administración
Nigeria también se enfrenta a los
mayores niveles de alerta de inseguridad
alimentaria y las agencias de la ONU
advierten de que es necesaria una
atención urgente para salvar vidas y
puestos de trabajo
vamos a Francia porque en la sede de la
UNESCO en París inició hoy una nueva
Ronda de negociaciones Internacionales
con el objetivo de alcanzar un pacto
global para limitar el uso y la
fabricación de plásticos y
particularmente en las orillas del río
sena que atraviesa la capital francesa
se acumulan toneladas de botellas latas
o bolsas de este material que preocupa
cada día más la comunidad científica
a las orillas del Río sena el plástico
se ha convertido en parte del paisaje
todos los días miles de fragmentos de
plástico son arrastrados a las Riberas
de su caudal dentro de un metro cuadrado
se encuentran cuatro kilos de plástico
20.000 piezas de escombros de los cuales
la mitad son gránulos de plástico
Industrial en la región de normandía
este geólogo Está tratando de seguir la
ruta tomada durante varios años por los
escombros si plasticla estos plásticos
cuando quedan atrapados en la zona de
algas en los depósitos de marea serán
aplasta contra la madera ejerciendo
múltiples presiones así se generan los
microplásticos
la mayoría de los plásticos miden menos
de 5 milímetros muchos de ellos
provienen de desechos más grandes que se
desintegran con los años y terminan en
el río los científicos advierten que no
todas las piezas terminan llegando al
mar y que pueden permanecer atascadas
durante años en una parte del río
formando zonas de acumulación de
sedimentos los barcos de limpieza
patrullan el río en un intento por
frenar esta plaga también se han
instalado redes de retención en las
salidas de alcantarillado
esta es la última Barrera que se puede
poner para poder capturar los residuos
sin red van al agua luego se rompe se
convierte en microplástico y luego se
acaba no lo verás no podrás atraparlo
una vez que las redes están llenas se
tienden y se analiza Su contenido
encontrando colillas toallitas
limpiadoras y principalmente artículos
de plástico como botellas
los científicos hacen un llamado al
público para que tome medidas reales lo
mejor que haríamos sería reducir el
consumo de plástico y sobre todo dejar
de consumir plástico de un solo uso
según estudios realizados en 2017 y 2020
el cena vierte entre 100 y 200 toneladas
de plástico al mar cada año
y la ONU conmemora hoy los 75 años de la
creación de Los cascos azules el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez calificó de esencial
la labor de este cuerpo dedicado a
estabilizar o vigilar zonas de conflicto
pero que no está exento de acusaciones
de violaciones de los Derechos Humanos
según información oficial la primera
misión empezó el 29 de mayo de 1948 para
supervisar La tregua entre las
comunidades árabe y judía en los
territorios palestinos hoy en día hay 12
operaciones en activo en lugares como
kosovo medio oriente El Sáhara
occidental o la frontera entre India y
Pakistán
hasta que las noticias Muchísimas
gracias por su atención
[Música]